A new era of exploration is beginning where
space is being opened up to private citizens.
Here’s a look at some of the rockets in
operation and others in development that could
take us farther than we’ve ever gone before.
The Long March 5 version B is currently China’s
most powerful rocket.
It stands just under 54 meters and can hold
at least 22 metric tons to low Earth orbit.
This model doesn’t have a second stage.
Instead, there’s an extra-large payload
fairing in order to accommodate the modules
of China’s upcoming space station.
The country is competing to become a dominant
player in space.
There’s a long way to go to match the long
line of American launch vehicles.
The Atlas V has sent spy satellites into orbit
for the U.S. military and NASA’s Perseverance
rover on a path to Mars.
It’s operated by United Launch Alliance (ULA),
a joint venture between Lockheed Martin and Boeing.
The 500 Series model, with a short payload
fairing, stands nearly 60 meters.
Various configurations can accommodate up
to five solid rocket boosters.
The Atlas V has relied on Russian engines
to fly for nearly 20 years.
That reliance will soon end when it’s replaced
by the Vulcan Centaur.
ULA’s next-generation launcher uses American-made
engines.
It’s expected to provide higher performance
than its predecessor and could make its maiden
voyage in late 2021.
The company has already snagged multi-billion-dollar
Pentagon launch contracts over the next few years.
This version, with a standard payload fairing,
measures about 62 meters tall.
The most powerful in the series is accompanied
by six solid rocket boosters.
ULA says it may try to re-use the most expensive
portion of its first stage down the road - the
pair of engines - by using a heat shield to
protect them as they fall back through the
atmosphere before being nabbed by a helicopter
mid-air.
Reusability is the key to SpaceX’s success.
The famous Falcon 9 has a first-stage booster
that lands back on Earth to be used again.
SpaceX’s well-known rocket has already flown
into orbit more than a hundred times, carrying
astronauts to the International Space Station
and launching satellites for a new internet
service called Starlink.
The Falcon 9 gets its name from the nine Merlin
engines that power the first stage.
Sticking three of the first stage boosters
together creates the Falcon Heavy.
A heavy lift vehicle means it’s very powerful.
This is the most powerful rocket in use - generating
more than 5 million pounds of thrust at liftoff
- the equivalent of 18 Boeing 747 planes.
During its debut in 2018, the Falcon Heavy
launched SpaceX CEO Elon Musk’s personal
Tesla Roadster to space driven by a mannequin
named ‘Starman’.
It can carry nearly 64 metric tons to low
Earth orbit - more than twice the payload
of the Delta IV Heavy which also consists
of three core boosters that make up the main body.
Unlike its SpaceX counterpart, the ULA rocket
can’t be re-used.
The first stage simply falls into the ocean.
It has been operating since 2004 mainly to
launch military payloads.
Retirement is around the corner.
The final flight is expected in 2023.
And as one retires, others are set to take off.
We’re still awaiting the debut of the massive
New Glenn from Jeff Bezos’ Blue Origin.
One of the reasons Bezos says he’s stepping
down as the CEO of Amazon is to focus more
on his space venture.
New Glenn is the company’s first rocket
to go into orbit.
It has a large seven-meter fairing and can send
45 metric tons to low Earth orbit.
The heavy-lift launch vehicle will be partially
reusable. The first stage will land and fly again.
The anticipated launch in 2021 has now been
delayed to late 2022 at the earliest.
At 98 meters tall, it’s similar in height
to the initial configuration of NASA’s Space Launch System.
The U.S. government’s flagship vehicle that’s
being built will be the most powerful rocket
in its history - intended to replace the retired
Space Shuttle.
The rocket uses four RS-25 engines designed
for the Shuttle program.
It also has two solid rocket boosters on either
side of the huge core stage - generating nearly
nine million pounds of thrust during launch.
This initial variation, Block 1, can carry
more than 27 metric tons to orbits beyond the moon.
The goal is to take people to the moon and
perhaps later, to Mars.
However, the first launch has slipped back
multiple times.
It now aims to fly uncrewed in late 2021.
The plan is for the SLS to evolve.
Versions like the Block 2 Crew will carry
larger payloads farther.
However, NASA’s suite of rockets is not
reusable.
Unlike Starship.
SpaceX’s fully reusable rocket under development.
Both the Starship spacecraft and the Super
Heavy booster are designed to land and fly again.
With a capability of carrying 100 metric tons
to Earth’s orbit, it will be the most powerful
rocket ever built and also the largest.
To give you an idea of just how big Starship
is, you can hardly see me right now unless
we zoom in really close.
I’m 5 foot 6 or about 1.7 meters tall standing
next to this beast which is 120 meters in height.
NASA has selected a modified Starship to land
the next man and first woman on the lunar
surface in a few years.
Starship is also scheduled to fly tourists
around the moon in 2023.
The grand goal of Elon Musk is to send people
to Mars and one day, build a city there.
So the future of spaceflight promises to be
unlike anything humanity has ever experienced before.
This video took months of working with an
animator to create.
In order to be as efficient as possible, I
took a class on how to be more productive
on Skillshare
Professionals put themselves on a schedule.
Author and video creator Thomas Frank helped
me organize and improve my workflow as I researched
and crafted this story.
My sponsor Skillshare offers thousands of
inspiring classes on a variety of topics.
MKBHD has great tips on how to grow a YouTube
channel.
Polymatter has a class on how to make animated
videos.
Each class is broken up into short lessons,
there are no ads, it’s for all skill levels,
and it’s yours for just $10 a month.
Plus, the first 1,000 of my subscribers to
click the link in my description will get
a free trial of Premium Membership so you
can explore your creativity.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.